Oh top guys on TV HD here and this is
the polka phone f2 Pro the successor one
of the successors to the super super
hyped polka phone from 2018 so this
phone like the first one will not be on
sale in the US but in markets like India
and the Philippines
this phone is fire for about 500 bucks
when you translate it so it's not quite
the same thing as the original which was
like the maximum value for $300 but hey
I'm okay with that and they also have
the regular polka phone f2 if you want
that but this phone is really
interesting from the inside out this one
checks a lot of the boxes you'd expect
to find in a high-end phone and I guess
basically they're adding the word pro
here add that just kind of means better
so from the overall build quality to all
the specs and all the numbers on paper
and all the included features it looking
pretty complete not only is it a pretty
big phone but you pick it up and you
immediately notice it's it's built well
it's solid to the point where it's
actually a little heavier than I
expected and it's made of metal and
glass so it doesn't creak or flex at all
and then you get plenty of extras a
little accent color for the power button
is sweet and once last time you saw a
phone with both a headphone jack and an
IR blaster that is a rare combo for 2020
the top of the phone also has that pop
up camera with an LED notification light
and you get this sweet emerald color
which you know I know pretty much every
high-end phone now is a glass sandwich
so it's kind of getting predictable but
at least it still feels good in the hand
and then of course the piece de
resistance
so hey say it is this this huge full
screen corner-to-corner uninterrupted
display and gives you haven't noticed
there are a lot of hole punch cameras
out there now and so this doesn't have a
hole punch doesn't have a notch and it's
doing my favorite method of getting rid
of the hole punch camera and the selfie
camera so we'll pop oh so now you have a
full screen corner-to-corner display six
point six seven inches of 1080p AM OLED
and it's a flat display too no fancy
curved glass which I am totally fine
with its HDR 10 plus certified and it
gets up to a comfortable but not in
credible 500 nits I'm just happy we have
displays like this on a phone of this
price though it is 60 Hertz and I think
if I was spending any more I would
definitely be looking for high refresh
rate but aside from that it's clear that
the standout feature of this already
great hardware package is the screen the
fingerprint underneath is pretty good
too at this point it's also kind of cool
that this is pretty much standard you
know this used to be a high-end only
feature but now it's started to trickle
down and it seems like the optical
fingerprint reader under the glass is
cheap enough that almost any phone can
include it and then the pop up camera
here has just a little extra little
little extra flair to it it's got the
LEDs on the module itself and actually
if you go into the special features
section in the settings you can
configure the front camera effects and
really customize the the sound effects
and the light color for every time you
open that front-facing camera oh it also
gives you a warning if you're doing it
too many times anyway on top of all that
it comes with this clear case which I'm
learning people really like especially
for getting rid of that little camera
bump on the back but if you're not into
that which I'm usually not then you can
always grab a skin from our channel
sponsor D brand to mix it up with the
color or the back texture finish you
know this matte black skin has never
done me wrong so I'll link it below but
honestly I think holding this phone you
know knowing I know it's 500 bucks but
if I didn't know it was 500 bucks the
only thing that would tip me off that
this isn't a $900 phone is there's a
little bit of rainbow banding on the
display from off axis and then also
these rounded corners I just noticed the
lower end phones for whatever reason
just usually have more swooping bigger
corner radius while the higher-end
phones can tighten that up make it
sharper more boxy other trade-offs you
can't tell just from holding it there is
no wireless charging
despite the glass back and there's also
no IP official IP water and dust
resistance rating those things cost
money oh and I just the vibration motor
as it buzzes in my hand I'm reminded
about it now you can't necessarily tell
that it is a cheap phone because of a
bad vibration motor because
our expensive phones with bad vibration
motors too but it's just it's never
something you unnotice unless you turn
haptics off you'll constantly be
reminded about a bad ratalie vibration
motor petition for everyone to just work
on those just just make those better
there is a single mono speaker at the
bottom of this phone which is bad news
on the spec sheet but honestly it gets
surprisingly loud and crisp and doesn't
even really distort that much at all at
high volumes i was listening to a
youtube podcast maximum volume from
across the room and it was doing great
this might be the best single mono
speaker i've ever heard in a phone now
it is you can still block the whole
thing with one finger that's the
downside of a single mono speaker but
they made it work here i've been using
this phone for a couple days and it's
got a lot of similarities from the
oneplus 8 pro I was just coming from
including the same chip snapdragon 865
which means it's also 5g enabled it's
about the same size as that phone and
the battery life here was actually
better it's got a hefty 47 hundred
million power cell and it's only
powering at 1080p 60 Hertz display so
you'd expect great battery and it
delivers great battery and for bonus
points it comes with this hefty boy in
the box this is a 30 watt fast charger
comes with the $500 phone now as you can
tell this is not a u.s. plug so I've
been charging it at regular speeds with
the charger I already have but good
battery life plus fast charging in the
box means I'm fine with no wireless
charging okay so this phone has quad
cameras on the back and cameras here are
where it becomes a little more obvious
especially to me if you're pretending to
be a high-end flagship versus actually
being a high-end flagship phone now when
you hear 64 megapixel quad camera array
capable of 8k video I mean that's a
pretty good set of numbers on paper now
that I've used it I'll say this camera
system is capable but it's not quite the
crazy high-end you might expect just
from the numbers the main camera it's
solid it is a 64 megapixel sensor but
it's gonna spit out 16 megapixel images
by default and you can see they look
fine
you know I'm not complaining they aren't
amazed
photos they're not particularly sharp or
great with colors or dynamic range or
anything like that but nothing's
terrible about them either until you get
to low light so that's fine you wouldn't
be buying this phone you shouldn't be
buying this phone for impressive image
quality at a low price you know that
would be you'd be looking along the
lines of pixel 3a or iPhone se but
unlike those phones this one also has an
ultra wide camera which is you know cool
to have it's a lot softer and not nearly
as good of a camera as the main one but
at least it's fun it serves its purpose
for larger subjects and that wider field
of view and then there's two more
cameras there is a 5 megapixel macro
camera and a 2 megapixel depth camera
now you might have been ready to write
those off you might have thought I was
gonna write those off but I use them
expecting to write them off and I was
actually fairly impressed the depth
camera seems to be doing at least
something for portrait mode shots I
don't use portrait mode much but the
cutouts here look good maybe a little
artificial if anything and the 5
megapixel macro camera is actually
decent now I've been shooting down all
those 2 megapixel macro cameras pretty
hard this year because they're just bad
they look bad but somewhere I guess
between those 2 megapixel macros and
this 5 megapixel the shots got a little
more usable and now macro shooting is
actually fun you can get some
interesting results colors are a little
muted but overall I'm not mad at them
for including this one and then the
selfie camera is again fine
it's about it on par with the main
camera it's funny they don't they don't
watermark the selfies by default but
they do watermark everything else but
yeah look at the details look at the
fibers the soft cotton shopped item can
be a few calm it's beautiful even the 8k
video is usable on this phone now it's
kind of funny it actually lags pretty
hard when recording and playing back
that 8k video on the phone which I
thought was a pretty bad sign but then I
imported it and looked at it on the
computer and it looks fine
so overall this is a capable camera
system it's fun it's not gonna give you
the best quality images and you should
look elsewhere if you want that but as
far as a decent
quad camera setup for 500 bucks this
phone nailed that really the software is
probably the only reason I couldn't rock
this phone every day my UI like I said
isn't my thing and even performance to
me because of my you I didn't feel
high-end like snapdragon 865 should feel
smooth with a 1080p display pretty much
always but it doesn't always here part
of that is the software part of that is
also probably that I'm spoiled at this
point getting used to all these high
refresh rate displays but I just
generally felt like it should be
stuttering less and should be smoother
and there was of course some cool
features like theme selectors and the
always-on display with the customizable
clock and things like that but there's
also occasionally ads inside the UI and
the stock apps but if I'm just
evaluating this whole phone as a package
for 500 bucks
it's a deal they did a really good job
here it's the real deal you know they
have the the non Pro poco f2 they have
the poco x2 and then there's just a
whole ton of other competition in this
space if you like different things about
different budget phones and I talked
about that in the poco x2 video so this
phone is a good sign of a lot of action
in that space we might think and see
that a lot of the improvement at the
very high end now is pretty incremental
lots of minor updates this year but
there's a lot of action down here so
this is exciting
good to see thanks for watching catch
you guys the next one peace